I think that a lot of the inward-facing
attacks from one section to the other
that we're seeing is not only it's not
good for the Democratic Party it's not
good for the country you know all of
these different labels and boxes whether
they are within the Democratic Party or
outside of it further divide us what do
you make of a general state of where the
Democrats are right now where it seems
to me that they that Biden doesn't
really want to run that that's just my
feeling is that he didn't run when he
you know after Obama left and that they
sort of brought him in because I think
the whoever the powers that be are they
kind of think well the progressives are
really taken over and if there's any
last chance for a more centrist
Democratic party we've got to throw it
to this guy do you see that split in the
party that there's sort of like this
ever diminishing more old-school
Democrat or liberal verse the democratic
socialism no I wouldn't say that as it
relates to Biden I don't doubt that he
wants I don't doubt that he wants to do
this it's something that he's done
another three times before in her fourth
time I think yeah this is at least is
there yeah so I don't I don't doubt his
intentions I think there's a bigger
question here about all of the different
factions that exist within the
Democratic Party and I think that a lot
of the inward-facing
attacks from one section to the other
that we're seeing is not only it's not
good for the Democratic Party it's not
good for the country you know all of
these different labels and boxes whether
they are within the Democratic Party or
outside of it further divide us yeah
they further tell us and this is this is
one of the challenges that people in
Washington have had anything from the
very beginning is I don't fit cleanly in
any one of those categories or those
labels and they're scratched ahead like
well we can't figure her out right which
is incredible because it's very simple
it's how most of us are we look at
things look at issues like does this
make sense or does it not make sense but
for me it's
it's I'm motivated not by an interest to
serve my party or to get somewhere
politically but I really actually want
to serve my country I really want to
serve the people of this country I'm
gonna do my best to do that and that's
how that's the lens through which I view
these different issues does this action
or policy in my view best help people
does it best help solve a problem or is
it something that's gonna be harmful or
cause further stress or struggle or pain
and suffering I'm trying to remember in
that first debate did you speak Spanish
I did not I did not know okay so that to
me was sort of like the perfect example
of I think you know this about me like I
mean identity politics to me yeah I I
truly believe that it is the most
dangerous force in American politics
today because it is what will turn us
it's the reverse of what the American
Dream was founded on that we would look
at each other by skin color and gender
and sexuality and all those I agree with
that and watching the other candidates
do it if you had done it - I would still
be saying the same thing it struck me as
the worst sort of pandering of like do
these people not speak English and if
they don't speak English perhaps we we
should speak English so that they learn
English so they can be more assimilated
and integrated and all of those things
and yet identity politics seems to have
completely taken over there's a woman we
did a 4th of July parade a bunch of them
actually in New Hampshire it was right
after that first set of debates and
they're all just it made an impact on me
there was a woman who was sitting with
her family and friends at the end of one
of the parade's that we stopped and we
said hi and she was from Central America
and she made it a point to pull me aside
and she put her her hands on my arm she
was very serious and she said whatever
you do in a future debate don't speak
Spanish she found that to be so
patronizing and and blatantly so and I
think that the identity politics that
are being used again to further divide
us to further drive separations between
us and purely for selfish political gain
is a real danger it
I agree it undermines that unity that we
have that doesn't come with groupthink
or saying well hey we're all exactly the
same we think the same way not at all
yeah it's that unity that we have in
recognizing our diversity and our
strength and who we are as Americans and
the principles and and freedoms that
make up the bedrock of our country so
it's interesting that that's how you
ended that because I just I when I was
tweeting out that you were coming on i
retweeted one of your last tweets which
was you know like a 30-second clip are
you talking about freedom and liberty
and things like that I love all those
words but those words now have been
really associated with the right and not
with Democrats do you find it odd that I
mean right in there there's a giant
American flag and all of those things
that I've got the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence in there
like do you find it odd that it seems
that the Democrats aren't embracing
those things weird running from them I'm
disheartened by it because of all of
those who have sacrificed for our
freedoms just yesterday morning I went
back and read Abraham Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address again you know that
short I think it was less than two
minutes where he very powerfully laid
out how best we can honor those who gave
their lives on that battlefield to birth
a new nation based on those principles
of freedom and liberty and equality and
that we have a government that is truly
of by and for the people and that's
where as as some folks in the media and
others are saying oh well tell us oh you
didn't make it the debate obviously
you're gonna drop out of the race I'm
not quitting I'm not dropping out of
this race because it is that same
inspiration that Abraham Lincoln spoke
of how we best honor those who
sacrificed all my brothers and sisters
in uniform who didn't come home with us
from Iraq that inspires me and motivates
me to continue forward in this campaign
because when it comes right down to it
it is the people in this country who
have the power to decide the election
and who have the power to make the kind
of change I believe we need to see all
right so on
libertarian side they love you on on the
war stuff yeah one of the things I was
getting a lot of tweets today well you
gotta ask her about guns you gotta ask
her about guns because the general
feeling you know they want their guns
basically so can you just sort of lay
out your position I think that I stand
up for second Amendment rights I don't
think it conflicts with the need I feel
we also need to have sensible gun safety
regulation I think that the fact that we
have not seen any kind of legislation
passed for a very long time is because
on one side you have people who say
there should be absolutely no regulation
whatsoever on guns and who can own them
and on the other side you have folks who
are saying that they want to repeal the
Second Amendment and they want to get
rid of guns completing take everyone's
guns away and you have those two
extremes on both sides kind of pointing
their arrows at each other with no real
real substantive dialogue and
conversation happening with that entire
space in the middle where where we
recognize that there's no conflict
between upholding our Second Amendment
rights also making sure that these guns
are not put into the hands of those who
would seek to do incredible harm to so
what would be a sensible law that is in
Fast already because that it always
seems to come down to that although yeah
I mean that's one that that we just
passed with some bipartisan support from
the house that's sitting in the Senate
now waiting for movement you know I mean
what would it do it would strengthen
background checks yes or extend them yes
and that's where I think that was
recently pointed out the shooter in El
Paso that if that law had already been
enacted that it was likely that would
have prevented him from being able to
purchase the guns that he bought what
would you say to the people that would
say well no matter how many laws you put
in place it's the bad guys aren't the
ones that follow the laws and that we
already have so many guns out there that
yeah you can pass whatever you want you
can say whatever you want but actually
bad guys don't follow laws and
these things are just gonna keep
happening well I think there's a few
elements to this there is some of these
cases in these mass shootings where they
are going and purchasing guns you know
whether it's from a dealer or a gun show
or whatever it is these are not people
who are going and you know buying a gun
from the trunk of a car so there's the
issue of how we can improve or
strengthen our laws to make sure that
those loopholes are closed but you're
right there is a problem with the guns
and the kinds of shootings that are
happening every single day in cities
like Chicago
you know people families so we're
thinking because Chicago has some of the
strictest gun yes no it is it is and
we've got to recognize that you know I
think that's unfortunate sometimes that
those who are calling for gun safety
reforms often turn a blind eye to the
reality of what's happening to families
every day in cities like that you know
where kids are being shot on their way
to school there's incredible violence
that's happening in some of these inner
cities that we as a country have to
recognize this is a deeper this is a
deeper challenge that we have as a
country that goes beyond passage of
legislation that is one piece of it but
it is not the only thing that's going to
help make sure that we're protecting our
kids and we're protecting our loved ones
when you hear things like the city of
San Francisco designating the NRA a
terrorist organization do you think
that's helping or or I don't think I
think that further deepens the divide
you know I I don't I don't support the
tactics that the NRA uses at all I think
that they are part of the problem not
part of the solution I think that what
we need as a country is for more
dialogue to happen between people who
feel like they sit on opposing sides of
this camp because they actually just
talk to each other I think most sensible
folks would be able to come together and
say you know when it comes right down to
it I think our goals and objectives are
probably closer together than we realize
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell